[Music]  emily has a wild imagination what she's  always asking for someone to understand  her and it feels like she becomes  increasingly alone but because she's  Emily she's conducting all sorts of  relationships with imaginary figures how  did you get inside girl I flew through  the window  Ruby is a figment of Emily's imagination  the B shows up every time emily is  feeling a bit lost or alone will you  dance with me and the bumblebee will  sort of come in and save the day  see you're so sweet I'm covered in  pollen baby hey this show explores that  being alone can be tough but perhaps not  was the very thing that generated such  powerful creativity may I have this  dance  you don't mind do you  you  you